so what you do is you create your own
curriculum that is above and beyond what
uh
is handed to you and i think you know i
think about what was handed to me
education wise and how i kind of blew it
and i talked about that in the book
there's a whole chapter on creating your
own curriculum
it was based on a tweet this guy did
frank fleming said that if you actually
took all the education
time 16 like 16 years of education
and kind of curated what you wanted to
do you would be batman
16 years of like martial arts philosophy
languages or you would be or economics
you would be batman
but instead you have 16 years of
education
and you're applying for jobs you know in
pharmaceutical sales and you're hoping
you will get that job
[Music]
i'm dave rubin and this is the reuben
report make sure to subscribe to our
youtube channel and click that
notification bell so you have a small
chance of seeing our videos
and more importantly joining me today is
the host of the greg gutfeld show the
co-host
of the five on fox news and the author
of the new book
the plus self-help for people who hate
self-help greg gutfeld welcome back to
the reuben report
thank you for having me dave and i'd
like to point out that i think i'm
almost as good-looking as you are today
but not quite quite a fine looking man
you've lost a little weight during the
lockdown you've been working out eating
right taking care of yourself
you know with the uh when the when the
gyms went away
i was forced to kind of like create my
own fitness routine
and i realized working out alone is the
greatest thing ever
it's the great you don't have to wipe
down a chair so i started i got
i got a bike and i just went all atkins
and i lost
i've lost almost well probably maybe
more than 40 pounds
i mean i've lost my child since like
march
so yeah i guess what happened was it was
i really kind of started in january
when i was at a wedding and somebody
took a picture of me and i won't say
that her name is kimberly guilfoyle
but this woman took a picture of me and
my wife and when i got
when she sent me the picture i saw my
wife there who looked great and this
little gnomish freak with just
sweaty gross and it was me
obviously and i was like going how do i
how does she
how does she put up with that how does
she go to in public places
with such a steaming pile of
unattractive flesh
so that's that i said this to somebody
else that
in this case fat shaming fat shamings
can be a really good thing because i was
fat shamed by that picture
so i started on the diet when i got back
from the wedding and then the shutdown
happened
and i just kicked into my peloton and
peloton and protein and
and you wrote a book called the plus so
p is definitely
uh your letter of the moment you do know
though that even if you're the only one
using the equipment you should
occasionally wipe it down
that's that's what elena tells me but i
still don't because it's my sweat
it's my sweat what what what could my
sweat do to me
that i haven't already done to myself
private isn't that how we got
coronavirus in the first place
you might be you might be right if it
indeed exists
don't take that out of context i'm
joking i've taken it very seriously
all right gut fell look you wrote a book
you wrote a book here this is what your
27th book how many books now
yes this is book number nine
or what i like to say yeah i like to say
it's eight more than yours
dave eight more books than yours i can't
even see your first book it's so early
it's like call me when you're on your
fifth book
then i can get the patches on my elbows
and the whole thing and be an esteemed
writer
like you you'll be like judd hirsch in
ordinary people
you are going into your sort of jd
salinger phase though of life i can tell
because you've got your house
in the undisclosed location in the woods
you occasionally tweet pictures you're
on a lake
surrounded by trees and things you're
sort of going into that you're
thought of as a as a cable news guy but
you're what really drives you is the
desire to be off the grid
hidden in the woods true or false i i
believe
that i was self-distancing before it was
cool
i am i don't know what it was it was
because i was younger i was more social
but i have no desire like you know me
when you're in new york it is impossible
to even get me out of my apartment
you know literally you end up yes
i made you come to my apartment when it
was destroyed
because i would rather sit in my
apartment that had just been flooded
than actually like oh david's going meet
me at this restaurant i go you know i
don't really feel like
but i'm like greg name the restaurant
it's on me
whatever you want you know grass-fed
this you're like could you just come to
my place i have
i have one beer yes
i'm not that bad i always have booze but
we did go to del frisco's
remember we did go to del frasco's
across the world that was
that that was nice nice guy
yeah so you was your brother right you
told me that was your brother
yeah okay i claimed it was my brother he
says he's my brother
i'm not sure um no but
let's talk about the the quarantine
stuff a little bit because because in
your book
you actually you i guess you added the
preface after you wrote the whole thing
because then you wanted to address the
quarantine stuff and they they let you
jam it in there
yeah it was interesting because we had
to have a discussion whether something
in the news ends up branding your book
or should your book be above it all so
i'm i'm the book's going to bed
and all this stuff is happening and the
book itself is about
a collective response to crap in your
life so that we all
share the risk and be better people and
this thing is happening and i'm going
i have this has to go in the book
because all of the things in the book
the collective response prison to two
ideas unbending minds
uh blaming and forgiveness all
fit you could all point all of these
tips in that direction
and um but there was like there were
people going like yeah but you don't
want to be a pandemic book and i go well
you know what
if this book had come out in 2016 we
would be talking about the trump
election
if it had been coming out in 12 2012 it
would be obama you know it or or
if it came out in 2001 it would be 911.
so you you you
can't ignore reality so i put it in
there and it
it in um it's weird a lot all the
chapters in this book
are are dealing with crap that happened
later
like even the riots in them all this
likes i talk about social media
i talk about uh uh marginalization
demonization all this stuff and it's
like everything is happening
and it makes i it's it kind of scares me
because i'm trying to be positive
and the book is trying to be positive
but we're in a time where we're not sure
if we can be positive anymore you know
no
well nobody's nobody's sure of anything
but i will go on the record gut felt as
saying that if anyone watching this
enjoyed don't burn this book
they will dig the plus because actually
a lot a lot of the themes
i mean this is why we do so much stuff
together lately a lot of the themes that
both of us care about
related to free speech what's happening
at the college is trying to keep
some semblance of western society
organized maintaining a sense of humor
through it all that that
really is what the thrust of this is
about but on the
on the self-help side do you sense that
people
over the last four months that there's
going to be like when when this thing is
done
if it's if it's ever done that that
there will be a real split where it'll
be like
some people really will have gotten
their lives in order lost weight learned
how to cook
started new hobbies et cetera et cetera
and then there will be this other set of
people that will just like completely
lost
control of their lives and i know both
sides
of that of that equation it's kind of
like the it's
it's like the education argument that
like you could just go to high school
check in and check out and you come out
worse or you can be that kid that goes
oh i want to do this i want to go i'm
going i'm going to be like the dana
perino i'm going to join the speech and
debate club
because that's going to make me better
and i'm going to and then i'm going to
go uh play
bad with field hockey i'm trying to
think of sports
but i mean it's like it's like lacrosse
create lacrosse thank you
so what you do is you create your own
curriculum that is above and beyond what
uh
is handed to you and i think you know i
think about what was handed to me
education wise and how i kind of blew it
and i talked about that in the book
there's a whole chapter on creating your
own curriculum
it was based on a tweet this guy did
frank fleming said that if you actually
took all the education
time 16 like 16 years of education
and kind of curated what you wanted to
do you would be batman
16 years of like martial arts philosophy
languages or you would be or economics
you would be batman
but instead you have 16 years of
education
and you're applying for jobs you know in
pharmaceutical sales and you're hoping
you will get that job
because you did not think about it like
what an
incredible opportunity so that's how i
started thinking about the pandemic is
like
okay the the cards that are being dealt
are limiting everything
like i can't go to the gym which i've
been going for 40 years i guess
to the gym like every week for 40 years
and that's over
and i know how much i eat i eat a
buttload of food
so this is not going to end well for me
also i tend to you know i
i like drinking and i'm going to be home
a lot and there's all so all of these
variables are pointing in a terrible
direction for me
and then i thought well what if i
decided to create
like a quotes got out of a system
uh rather than goals and so i like cut
out
the get cut out the starches and the and
the carbohydrates and then
and then it's like get a bike and get up
every morning and start early and then
and also what i get up every morning and
walk before i exercise
and i just to get sunlight all this
stuff and all of a sudden it's just like
i it made me it's like i i took
i went to school to become a better
person which was weird because that's
what the book's about the book was about
becoming better
at being you which is kind of
interesting
well it's kind of interesting because
how can you become a better dave rubin
well i mean i've i've done it you know
what i mean
what you're going through right now is
where i was a year ago you'll get to the
perfect place greg come on
and i'm going to help i'm going to help
you get there um
thank you but it is kind of interesting
because you wrote the book obviously
before the pandemic then you add this
part about the pandemic but yeah what
you were writing about
and sort of getting your life together
really kind of is what you're trying to
show
for other people but that kind of
reminds me you wrote a piece on
foxnews.com about a year ago
about how people can educate themselves
outside of the system you can learn from
jordan peterson you can go on youtube
and learn from biologists and chemists
and all of those things
does that strike you the fact that young
people
still even now as we watch colleges
collapse
does it seem just completely crazy to
you that they're still putting all that
money in on that
experiment yeah there needs to be okay
okay so there's that old experiment that
we see is failing
and it looks like the pandemic is gonna
push it
online and elsewhere and then here is
the perfect thing which is to have
you know shows like yours or youtube
anything on youtube like you getting a
biology class from brett weinstein or
getting a philosophy class with jordan
peterson
but the the uh instructors have to be
really good
it can't just be like youtube where you
like i get
i get stuck in a youtube black hole
looking for um guitar instruction
and so it's like how to play rockabilly
guitar so i hit that
it's 30 minutes and the guy's talking
for eight minutes
and he's like and he's just talking he's
holding his guitar and it's like i can't
do this
i need like somebody who's an instructor
and i think that's the only missing
point because you have the you have the
vehicle you have
youtube you've got the internet and you
have the desire the people to want to do
this you have the pandemic that is
forcing people in this direction
all that's missing is the pro the
stylistic
charismatic instructor and i go back to
peloton
every time what peloton did to jim's
is what instructors are going to do to
college so
i no longer need to go to a gym again
because the peloton instructor is so
amazing so smart and so
authentic and and i love this girl
hannah frankson she's british
i get up every morning and she gets me
on that bike and she she
it's what she's done is she's taking the
product and she's
delivered it to you in the best way
possible that's the way
there has to be colleges that start up
with that model that says okay
you need great professors and they got
to be funny they got to be smart they
got to be
not bad looking everybody in peloton is
great looking
and they're funny and and uh and so i
think that's the peloton model for
education is going to be the solution
for all of this and i'm not the i think
that scott adams talk
said this to me before in an interview
that it's like this is the step
that's necessary is to get likable
talented
persuasive people to be the instructor
and so now you're going to get those
people leaving these colleges
but there has to be something to come to
and it's got to be like jordan peterson
teaches
uh introduction to uh apologetics or
whatever
you know greg i'm not a uh a
fancy cable news host so i don't have a
peloton i've got a regular
old elliptical something or other but is
this woman talking directly to you or
you're in a live class every day what
what what's going on there with the
peloton
i think she's talking to me dave i yeah
there's nobody else no okay so um
i'm telling you you get this bike
you will it will change your life about
it in terms of
because what happens is they jumble up
the uh
the types of uh uh segments so you're
not doing 45 minutes on a bike you're
doing we're gonna do some hills then
we're gonna do some sprints and then
we're gonna
sit down and then we're gonna stand up
and before you know it it is over it's
like you're done
and they're talking to you the whole
time so they do live classes in the
morning sometimes in the middle of the
night
and then i i never do live classes i get
up at around 10 a.m
uh or 11 a.m i will do it and i will
find my favorites leanne hainsley
my favorite ones are the british ones
they have a german one
this german woman from uh uh who when
she's
yelling the stuff it's not
it doesn't make somebody whose name is
gut belt feel very comfortable
but she's great she's like get on the
bike
get up you can do it and i'm just like
going crap and i do it
but um it's so good if it works it works
yes but now i've got but see that to me
is a plus that somehow they took an
existing
issue and they which i guess they took a
spin class
and they brought it inside so you don't
have to go to the gym and so that to me
has changed
and it is expensive the bike's at least
two grand i think the bike's too grand
but equinox i mean equinox
is 250 bucks a month i think 300 at
least right
i just canceled my membership i'm doing
all my stuff at home now
yeah but the thing is i haven't canceled
equinox because i'm under the assumption
that they've
put a stop to it they must have because
legally that would be against the law
but i don't think i'll ever go back and
it's a great gym but you know
and two gyms right now have go ahead
you might you say you say equinox i say
equinox
where does that put us as people
you know i don't know i think that's a
certain kind of classic
closet racism that you're reflecting in
the way you pronounce it
i can actually tell i'm i'm re i have uh
what's it called that i'm an i'm an
ethnic gnostic
i got i heard that from somebody who's a
preacher an african-american preacher
he says that there's all these ethnic
gnostics meaning that they can tell
how racist you are just by either
listening to you or looking at you
because they're gnostic i'm not even
sure what it means but it's such a great
word i think i'm going to use it today
on the 5.
you like new words incorporating new
words into the show
and new new linguistic tricks so
all right so i really like the title of
the book because the plus the idea
basically that
that there are positive things out there
that you can aspire to that you can kind
of incorporate your life and everything
else
um we've talked about this a little bit
on your show but
one of the things that i'm kind of
amazed by right now is that a certain
set of people and i would say generally
politically they're on the right
they are actually much happier than the
people on the left
and i don't think that has to do solely
with politics
ar are you with me on that do you see a
fundamental reason that even when i
just just the fox crew that i've become
friendly with so you
and dana and and uh tucker and hannity
like
i from what i know i i i know you the
best
person but like everyone's happy they're
all happy and it's and i know why
they're happy
and it's it's there are three kind of
things that i think
are that that make them happy and i
don't really aspire to them which is
weird but
um family community religion and i think
that
i think that like uh if people build
these inner circles
out outward they have themselves and
they have their family then they have
their community and they have religion
or it might
be religion might be the closest thing
but those are the things now i'm not
religious
but i understand why it works and
religious people tend to be incredibly
nice
and and and forgiving and will help you
and part of being religious
is actually helping people being
charitable that's the same thing
and it also bleeds into their family and
their community there is a certain
you know possibility or potential for
intolerance intolerance as you know
among religions and that's always
something to be watched out for
but it provides a structure for people
so i think but it's true it's like
uh everybody's very happy like i i am uh
i'm probably more uh uh i i think i
i swing between polls in terms of
happiness and unhappiness
because i'm neurotic so i i would say
that i'm at my happiest point in my life
but that's still not as happy as they
are because of my neurosis
and anxiety prevents me from jumping
completely
into the happiness pool you know but
greg
as a as a self-help guru i can tell you
now uh that it's
it's that neurosis but it's that
neurosis that that's sort of
creating why what you do works because
whenever i'm on
on the greg gutfeld show when if we text
after you always say the same thing to
me if it's a good show you go we got all
the serious stuff out at the beginning
and then we had fun and i think that
that's what people are responding to
so it's like your show i'm sure you know
the numbers i mean you are
crushing it crushing the late night
people right now
and it's like they're the ones that have
30 writers
they've got you know millions and
millions of dollars worth of budgets and
all that stuff
and they're miserable and unfunny how
many people work on your show
eight maybe and and in terms of writing
that show
uh and we used to do this every night
with red eye with roughly the same crew
and it it's uh like i write my monologue
and then tom and holly
and this other kid gene will work on the
segments and the graphics i better not
leave anybody out and of course cat
does her thing which is really good and
tyrus writes his stuff
it's um and it's naturally funny
and smart and you aren't having you
aren't sitting in a air-conditioned room
with 13 people
who are all making six figures ordering
in let's order in and
write 40 more jokes for kimmel's
monologue uh
nobody right i mean i i'm opening myself
up when i say nobody writes my jokes
because that's like we can tell greg
but i like yeah yeah yeah but i always
start with like okay i have a serious
point to make
and then you work your way through that
and then at the end there are these
jokes that
come up absurdities and i instead of
just leaving them out i put them in
and it always helps to be you know to
have targets that are hilarious i mean
cnn never gets old
you know as long as you have chris cuomo
and don lemon i'm gonna have a monologue
and uh or brian stelter i mean these are
the gifts
that you know keep on slobbering
well that's the thing because it's like
if you look at the cnn crew
not only do they all seem miserable and
we can and the lies and all that stuff
but like you guys are having fun like
there there doesn't seem to be any level
of fun there and i'm not saying the news
has to be fun
per se but i think it does it does color
something else beneath it or something
like that think about like
the daily show with jon stewart was
having fun during that period
i don't see that anywhere even on comedy
central you really don't see
any fun i i i've said this to you before
i always use
i call it the dean wermer effect that
like for the longest time in animal
house
the republicans were always dean wermer
and everybody else right pluto
and the and delta house we the whole
goal of
you know when andrew was alive and and
uh i was working at huffington post was
flipping so yeah so the republicans
would be
at some point would become delta house
and deliver
and the left would become uh dean wermer
and that's what's happening
you know this you left dean wermer and
you're watching this i think
i'm curious about how you feel about
matt taibi because i feel really guilty
about the
all the times that i kind of dismissed
him as just a left-wing
the way he dismissed me i'm sure or he
didn't maybe know who i was
but i see him now and i go like he's
dave rubin he's
two months away from you becoming good
right well i
i feel like it you know it's it's like a
little pat on my back it's like oh
all of these people now are just saying
what i said years ago so
yeah you know it's like when you're when
you're ahead of the curve you somehow
feel behind it in a way when it starts
getting to the moment of of uh
mainstream you're like ah
yeah but it's good like i don't i i
don't know that he
he knows me specifically but i'm like
yeah you're just writing the same exact
stuff i said four years ago
that's really great you know yeah you
see that though you see that with brett
weinstein you see that with his wife
when you listen to that what they're
what they go through and by the way
probably the most i guess disturbing
thing about this last couple of months
is that how
right brett was about um
what's the name of this college green um
evergreen evergreen that would happen in
every green
evergreen has gotten out of the zoo it's
out of the zoo
and and it's all over the place and it's
like he said that was gonna happen and
i am trying to maintain a positive like
this is not going to get any worse
because
there's no slippery slope with this you
either either have law and order or you
don't you got to stop this
but so far he's he and his brother have
been pretty
uh dead-on on this stuff makes me very
nervous
so for a guy like you that doesn't want
i know you don't want the whole
system to collapse but i think you also
i think we're probably similar in this
way you understand
the why it's collapsing yeah what do you
see is the way that we can kind of get
out of this thing
well i i mean i'm gonna sound like a
broken record because i
am i do agree with donald trump that
fake news is the enemy of the people i
mean i don't know if you could find
a clearer statement than tear down the
wall maybe
because almost all of these things that
are happening to us right now
tend to be these psychological conflicts
that are ginned up
and i think if you go to any serious
issue where there is an issue you could
talk about
police and policing communities serious
issue does the media add or subtract to
it
it's a negative it's a minus it's not a
plus the more that the american public
understands how to perceive what's going
on
on television at cable television and
not to trust it
the better off we're going to be i think
the first thing we have to do is
understand
that this is not our friend that this
this this is a
this is a machinery of division that's
trying to get us to eat each other alive
and they and then they don't see it like
you see on cnn going you know we
this what's happening yesterday you know
what's happening in portland is you know
we don't condone it but it's being
exaggerated
you know by the pouncing right-wing
media no they found a
body in in minneapolis and they burned
out you know uh
pawn shop that ain't pouncing that's a
corpse
so i mean it is i think that the first
thing is realization
that this institution is gone it's your
enemy
and and uh and i and fake news is the
enemy of the people
sounds so you know it sounds so trumpian
but it actually god we knew this right
we always it's like like if you and you
by the way
you know this i know this specifically
because
anytime anybody writes about you it's
never
right it's never it's like you you get
you know i've been written about i don't
know
a bunch of times and if the person loves
your show it's going to be great
but if they're coming from a liberal
institution in which they have editors
they can't compliment you they can't see
your point of view
they can't even empathize so they'll go
like dave rubin claims to be a
traditional liberal who became
disillusioned with the progressive left
what he likes to call in a mocking
manner regressive
we met dave but and he's like and then
there's like six or seven cutting
remarks
and then some comment from somebody who
doesn't like you
well here's the thing about dave that
you probably aren't aware it's like
and so it builds and you go like wow
this whole story
was just designed to take me down and
it's not true
i didn't say that i've had instances
with
reputable journalists where i go that
didn't happen that didn't happen and
then if you end up on twitter
calling people out you could be there
all day you know and i've like i've
called out
four or five people and they've
retracted others don't but
um you know it's if you if you are the
object of a story
you know this you knew that you know how
this works they seek a narrative
they need to tell a story if the beach
doesn't have a shark
it's not a story so they need to have a
shark at that beach
right well i love every time when i get
advanced warning that the daily beast or
huffpo
or the times is going to do something on
me and then you know someone will reach
out
and usually when it's when they're like
24 hours from prince so they know i have
to rush a statement
and then i'm just like no i'm not going
to play their game and then at the
bottom dave rubin refused to comment on
this
piece yes
yeah but but it's not just it's not just
journalists though because
you i mean you're on fox every day you
know there there is a team of people
at media there's a non a non-profit that
are dedicated
uh to for you to raise your eyebrow in a
re in a weird way and that can prove
that you're a racist
and that is constant for me my eyebrow
always goes up
but you know what i always try to appeal
to a lot of these
people there's not that many of them i
don't know on twitter or
privately and i'll go like do you really
i go do you really want to do this for a
living
i mean your job is to watch me and hope
that i
screw up so think about that as a as a
career
that you are not successful your role
is that i a successful person fails your
job is to sit there
and just hope that maybe i lose my
temper or i say something that could be
misconstrued
because what they really do is they take
something and find the worst intention
out of it
so it's like uh you know uh what they
just take
stuff out of context well they did that
well the big one the big one a couple
weeks with you was uh one of the guys at
media matters was claiming that you were
high uh basically in effect
hiding information about coronavirus and
you pulled up a clip that you were
talking about coronavirus you talked
about it
yes was it literally the end of january
yeah yes
yeah and you know what that guy still
maintained that he was right he's like
well you know you know what
it's just fox in general i don't know
you actually said me
and look at this and i will show you and
also tucker was early on too
and i'm like and i go you should you
should do the right thing guy but he's
no longer
i don't that guy no longer does me it's
like
i think what happens is they burn out
through self-reflection
when i always like by the way that guy
was that guy ain't young doing that work
so i always think that somebody who's
stuck with that job is stuck with that
job
because i can't imagine me when i was in
my 20s
i wouldn't have done that job i i was i
worked at prevention magazine and i
wrote about
health practices for the elderly which
sounds terrible but i learned how to
interview doctors
doing what they are doing in their 20s
or their 30s or their 40s
seems to me like it's soul-crushing that
you a
that you have to do this and so i always
try to appeal
to that i mean it's funny to see the the
network that they bounce to like when
you leave media matters do you now go to
the daily beast
or you might go to vice when and vices
now nothing
nothing but a a a big
pile of woke garbage it's hilarious to
think that that was a
a daring magazine in the 90s and and
what is it it's not even a thing and um
but my point is they're it's a it's a
self-contained organism but what happens
is they send these like
things out to get you fired so they're
just kind of like a cancellation
organ and um and you have to be on your
toes with it i
you know you try not to you know you you
you look at them i tend to get pissed
off if it's
if it's something that's going to damage
me so i will come at them
though there is an argument to just
ignore them because most people do and
over time they have lost their cachet uh
i think
but they will like if they have a chance
to come out think about this
so you dave you take a risk you take a
risk
you start your own business you lead you
you create
an island for yourself to kind of like
you make yourself immune to cancellation
which is the solution
and yet there are people that still want
to destroy you precisely for that reason
think about that they want to destroy
you because you
you refuse to be destroyed so as a guy
yeah so as a guy that just wrote a you
know a self-help it's a self-help
mockery in a way but it's also but it is
self-help at the same time
what do you think it is about that type
like what do you think the dividing line
is between a type of person who wants to
take care of themselves and their life
versus the type of person that wants to
because we see so much of this
everywhere
just take out other people
well i have a chat i have a chapter on
this in the book and i talk about how
the the most manic of these individuals
uh are according to research are
incredibly uh
anti-social and they can't tell if it's
the chicken or the egg
is it their own beliefs and ideologies
that make them anti-social or is it
something
about them that makes them that way and
when you look at what's going on
in this in the streets of portland and
seattle there's
there is a mental issue going on there
they do not
seem stable so i think that these are
people that have lost contact
with their loved ones their family i
don't think these are people that come
home for thanksgiving
and help with the turkey right i think
that their
joy in life is to humiliate
and attack and have you hear their their
screams and their cries
i do think that it's we're living in an
age of hysteria
and i think it's also bleeding into
other certain segments
that i can't even talk about certain
activists
who do not represent the people they
claim to
there's a great um oh there's a great
clip of this african-american
cop in portland talking about how a
black activist came up to him and said
hey you know um you know how do you feel
about george floyd as he's talking
a white leftist female comes over and
goes don't talk to him
she's telling a black woman not to talk
to him it's and you realize
okay this is a this is a mental issue
this is
uh so i think that you almost have to
pull them out of this cult
you and i aren't in cults because the
measure of a cult is the ability to
admit when you're wrong
like i admit i'm wrong on like at least
once or twice a year no once or twice
like pretty regularly um uh
well not only do you admit greg nelly do
you admit you're wrong can you tell the
good people what happened this very week
on the greg gutfeld show with you and
cows you made a major
a major admission yes uh emission nice
one
or omission emission
i've noticed this that um
we all have and even adams has said this
but he won't admit
what what mistakes that we have these
like really embarrassing things
that we that we won't voice because
we're for example
in seinfeld it was george costanza
didn't want to go to a flea market
because he thought there were fleas i
always thought that
i thought that too there were flea
markets in belmont california and my
friends were running oh i'm not going
there
because i thought please so two i have
two
idiotic beliefs in the last uh month
that i've talked about one on the five
i thought veal was a separate animal i
didn't know that it was like a baby cow
no idea i thought like when you order
veal it's like ordering lamb
or it's just a different animal so
that's embarrassing but i didn't know
that cows were only female i thought
that a cow was just like there was a man
so that's stupid but it's like i i don't
mind confessing that i know these things
i i'm an idiot because i know for a fact
that
everybody everybody
feels that way i mean there are people
that think that there might be 52 states
uh because they get confused between a
deck of cards and the united states and
also you have those two states that are
outside
sometimes i'm going like is it 52 or 50.
52 or 50.
i should check because i get confused
you know is it 48 plus 2
it's 48 plus 2. also there are things
like when you think about geography in
general
that you can get stuff totally wrong
because
uh you kind of skipped over it and
somebody could trick you
into thinking that something was part of
something when it really wasn't
um there are parts of europe that i
might have thought were parts of
other places but is all of that is all
of that really just because
everyone seems to pretend that they know
everything at all times net neutrality
was gonna kill everybody solomoni's
death was gonna start world war
three yes you know there's some the
russia thing the ukraine thing with the
iran nuclear deal people who
have no jobs no people who can't get
their lives together but they know
everything about string theory and
economic policy and everything yes
i try to do that you know who knows
every i'm convinced who
knows everything according to his fans
is john oliver
man did you see his 30 minute on net
neutrality it'll change your life it's
like
no thanks i'd rather be ignorant i don't
i don't think i need to know 30 minutes
on net neutrality because i know where
it's going to end up
in the same place it always does and to
your point it's always the same place
and i think it's helpful like like
string theory
this is this is the blessing and curse
of podcasts that
you could do your curriculum i'm going
to learn about quantum physics
at quantum mechanics or quantum gravity
you put quantum in front of everything
and suddenly people like who is this guy
but i enjoy
quantum leap yes i love that actor
there was scott bakula scott bakula and
oh the other guy
who played tom who played booth uh who
played mr booth in blue velvet
who was the pointed green hair the boy
was in the movie boy with green hair
he was in air force one i just watched
it this weekend uh
stu uh god geez louise if only somebody
here could google the boy with green
hair that did you see that movie as a
kid
do you ever see that movie his boy wakes
up with green hair i don't think i've
seen it
very scary amazing i saw it as a child
probably came out in the 1940s 1950s
but the guy we're talking about stuart
stu
stan uh uh step
uh george we should do you know what i'm
gonna do wait greg watch this i'm gonna
do something i've never done this on my
show before but my director is remote
right now
he's in my ear matt i want you to google
the actor that we're talking about he
was in quantum leap he was not scott
bakula but the other guy
and apparently he had green hair as a
child can you get me that actor's name
this is the most cable news i've ever
been right now yeah and he was the guy
that ran the bordello
dean stockwell dean stockwell
i hope he's still alive dean stockwell
did you ever see blue velvet wait hold
on let me go back to the control room
matt is dean stockwell still alive yes
stand by greg
i hope he is
still alive no wow he's 84 and still
alive at least as of this taping
road trip we are going on a steam stop
did you
i have to ask you because my favorite
movie of all time is blue velvet
and dean stockwell's character was the
guy that ran the whorehouse
that dennis hopper came to and it's one
of the greatest scenes
in any movie um anyway that's my did you
what you look like you've not seen blue
velvet
i actually i i haven't seen it believe
it or not but gut felt i got to tell you
i love you but your movie
recommendations over the last couple of
months have really been disastrous
i'm talking about i'm texting you one
morning i'm like i don't know what we're
going to watch tonight i've watched
everything you're like oh
you got to watch the color of something
with nick cage
i literally i got brain damage in the
middle of the movie it was that hard
whoa whoa whoa whoa so wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute that's the
protocol
with the color of space
no no no not the color of space it's
it's a remake
the uh the um officer the um
i can't swear right now because of you
um no you can square it
swear people will like it okay it was a
remake
of a harvey keitel movie but it really
wasn't and it's called port of call
and it's by the guy who did grizzly man
um the director
um who did grizzly man werner herzog did
it
and it's called um cop officer bad
lieutenant
porter call and it's got iguanas in it
how could you not love that movie
how could you not love that movie the
nick cage it's one of nick cage's best
films
dick cage also if you've ever you didn't
like mandy did you
mandy where are you no i i tried to
watch that because of you too
i watched it for about a half hour and i
couldn't take it anymore i was sitting
in a pool of my own vomit
and i thought i got felt that's
wednesday
[Laughter]
this is what you call a tangent this is
the beauty of youtube
that you don't have the luxury as a as a
cable news host
to do these do these things um actually
i want to tell you about something
somewhat serious actually because just
in the last couple days
uh you know tucker did this end of the
show monologue
about what the new york times is doing
right now and they've basic they've
basically threatened to dox him
they already did one version of this and
we know that people have shown up at his
house before and all that
uh i feel that this is the next level of
where this is all going that they've
said it's okay to burn down stores
violence isn't violence
words are violence but violence isn't
it's very confusing but the next level
of this will be that
it will be it will be something to the
effect of
can republicans go to public places
right and can republicans have homes
that are not doxed
are you worried about that like what do
you make of this thing oh um
i'm worried in a number of ways that
i've actually acted on it
uh for the last couple of years actually
i've acted on
uh on certain things to for safety
reasons and we've talked about that
before
um i find it interesting that all the
things that you talked about are okay
but they're charging that couple for
brandishing that weapon
when the mob broke down the gate and was
in front of their house
so they're actually telling you not only
can you be threatened
not only can your uh uh public and
private property be vandalized
but you cannot defend yourself and and
it's also what i mean tucker
you know it it say what like they cannot
deny this is not a political act
it's not rachel maddow that they're
doing this to
it you know it's not anybody on cnn it
is tucker carlson
the most i guess the most successful
cable host in history
in terms of ratings i believe the
eclipse uh o'reilly
so it's not a coincidence that it's the
new york times
that is doxing him they're not doxing
chris cuomo he's well he kind of doxed
himself during the corona
he does but uh you know it's like it's
it's it's so it's it's ha
if these actions were a two-way street i
would get it
but all these errors and all these
prosecutions
and persecutions happen in one direction
and the direction is towards people like
tucker people like you
uh uh you know if they can my guess is
if they can find out where anybody lives
that they disagree with they would have
no problem i mean look what they did i
always use the covenant
covington kid there was no shortage of
people
wanting to make sure people knew where
that kid lived and where you know and
they were everybody was looking hey are
his pictures of him in high school you
know
people these are political persecutions
going on right now now i know that the
times today i think they might have
issued a response saying they weren't
going to dox him but
but that's after tucker called him out
you know so there was clearly something
going on there
and i mean the guy had a move you know
and uh
yeah it takes a lot for tucker to move
it takes a lot for tucker to change his
clothes
you know he's always wearing the same
clothes i can't imagine him
ever leaving his house because he was
threatened but i
mean they came to his door they
vandalized his house
the new york times man i don't know what
it is are they completely
overtaken by the young woke or are they
just terrified by the young woke who
worked there
we knew this was going to happen when
you graduate from college you got to go
somewhere
and they ended up at the times and they
end up in corporations too
dave you know they you know it's gonna
it's gonna take down
it's gonna take down every corporation
and every institution that lets it in so
the times yeah
i think i think both is the answer to
what you just said is did they let it in
like willingly or are they just afraid
of it i think it's both
it's both things what do you make of the
uh
of the last liberals that are scattered
throughout the galaxy
you know the ones that maybe are still
afraid of showing up on your show
because i know you
you talk to people privately that
wouldn't want to be you know that they
wouldn't want to be associated with you
you would have no
absolutely associating with them but
what do you make of say the people that
were in my position
a couple years back that that still it's
like ah
i just don't want to be seen with
gutfeld or tucker
because that's worse than having my
house burned down
i'm thoroughly uh compassionate and i
take
i i like i never uh pressure anybody
to do anything because i know that the
change that they're going to experience
is going to get ugly i'm trying to think
of a a good example is anybody in a band
anytime i do anything with somebody in a
band their fans
are going to be so shocked not because
they hate me but fox news so like a
buddy of mine
um who's in uh power trip you know
we we met on we met on twitter we became
friends we went
him me and his dad went out drinking in
texas uh he did my podcast
and like i'm on i'm you know i'm on
twitter and there are these people going
i really love it when like bands like
power trips you crap
all over uh fox news and gutfeld and i i
just tweeted at the guy to go
i don't think you'll like this podcast
and it's like it's it's the
i like the the cognitive dissonance when
they go you know it's weird how dare two
people who disagree with each other get
along
i mean what kind of philosophy is that
when you think that's wrong
like that somehow if you and i disagree
i cannot be friends with you
because somehow your opinions are going
to rub off on me or mine are going to
rub off on you
and that's wrong it's it's it's and i
i feel bad for i'm trying to think of it
like there are people that have done
my podcast who won't do my show and
vice versa um but i don't you know i
don't
like i sometimes i do them a favor
because i go like i don't want i don't
want
uh i just don't want a crowd like when
ariel pink
did red eye he got you know all these
freaks went after him uh
any any like like uh uh
music websites that are what music
websites are populated by
the scott adams uh definition of the the
non-talent stack
the person that has no talent other than
one thing and it's barely
so when you go to music blogs they're
usually people that have no
wisdom no acumen about anything and so
whenever
anybody outside the music world does my
show
they have to write about it and cancel
that person
it's like when they found out that
thelma houston was doing a duet with
morrissey
and and so uh uh uh pitchfork
like contacts are we want to know why
are you doing a duet with morrissey
instead of saying wow it's amazing that
she
is back and she's doing something with
one of the greatest singers of all time
and yeah he's a right winger big deal
you know uh i'm sure it wouldn't matter
if he was
you know supporting corbin or a
with the uh gastrointestinal disorder
that's ibd
no ibm yes that's that's yes ibs
completely different thing but uh yeah
that's
actually ibs
stupid i'm sorry no you're you're doing
it
you're doing just fine you yes you're
doing just fine
i feel like maybe you need some water or
something you're you're [ __ ] through
here
no no no but what is that is that
you must be on some special you must be
on some special drink now
no i got uh this is my third cup of
coffee in my unicorn mug and then i got
some water here
in a gut falls uh monologue uh uh
uh red solo cup so i'm drinking it but
it's so it's it's
so incredibly hot where i am right now
it's got to be almost
100 i think and uh so you know i'm a
little sweaty maybe
do you think uh you like any of the
stuff like
going back to studios you know you're
not doing your show in front of a live
studio audience anymore but but even the
five you you guys used to all be in a
room together
or even the late night shows do you
think any of it's coming back or do you
think that the
putting the virus aside and that
whatever's true or not true about that
but just that the companies are going to
look at the numbers and be like wait a
minute why the hell were we paying for
these live studio audiences when the
ratings are
actually better now the rate but the
thing is so you have
you have all these variables people are
home so the ratings are higher
right like like the five was killing it
during
march and april was like we were having
like six million or something crazy
number
we were like huge um now we're kind of
in a normal phase or
it's still pretty high about three and a
half million depending on whether trump
speaks or not
but okay so that's gonna fudge the
numbers a bit
but it you're right in the sense that
there's a lot of things you don't need
anymore
i will say this though the five suffers
because there's this two second delay
and it always sounds like we're
interrupting each other and that we
don't like each other and that we're mad
at each other because
let's say i wanna be finished talking
and then
i'll jump in to say something he doesn't
hear me because there's a two second
delay so he starts talking again
and then we overlap and then it's like
hey i was talking well i was talking
it's it's
it's so bad so it's these um the the
delays are terrible
um and also it it handicaps me even more
because i'm a wise ass i'm supposed to
be at the table and while you're saying
something i'm supposed to insult you
under my breath but loud enough for
everybody to hear it or i'm supposed to
make fun of dana
and embarrass her and when you're on
remotes i i'm completely cut off i
cannot like
if i yell something it's gonna be a two
second delay
and it's gonna come later and then
they're gonna be laughing and then it's
gonna
[ __ ] everything up it drives me so it's
like so instead when i'm doing the five
i compare it to this
when you're on around a table it's like
a great
game of pickup basketball when you're
doing this
remote thing it's like you're at a
batting cage everybody's in their
separate batting cage
and they're all swinging for the fence
but you're not having any conversation
you're just
and no and like if somebody else is
batting you're not really looking
you're kind of looking at your notes
getting ready for your swing at the bat
and so it's not a conversation anymore
and um but
like you said it's like they're still
selling ads and there and
shows are still rolling along i think
the gigi show
will pro i mean i don't know how you do
an audience and i don't see this
happening before 2021 either
but right i don't i don't see them i
mean you can have a winter time which
means you're probably going to have a
return of different flus and different
illnesses and corona
and nobody's going to want the legal
ramifications i mean i guess you could
sign a waiver when you entered an
audience thing but uh you know i had two
events canceled i'm do i think i might
be doing an event
but i don't know i can't say i can't say
it but anyway uh
most of all my all my stuff has been
canceled so uh which is
you know no one wants to hurt anybody
unless it's in a bar late at night
you're getting paid to do it yeah yeah
that was very broad no one wants to hurt
anybody we could probably come up with a
couple
but it is it is kind of interesting that
you mentioned the delay thing and doing
this stuff all through skype because
even
even in the course of this where you
know we know each other i've stepped
i've stepped on you a couple times
because you miss
i can see you right now but you miss a
little bit with the
little bit with your body and then next
thing you know we're kind of babbling
over each other and that does change
what a little bit of the magic
is of television yeah it and i think
people who the people who watch these
shows like
the don't just like the politics of it
they like us so
uh they like to see us uh talk to each
other and
and uh and and have fun and that's it's
a little bit harder i was watching
yesterday
an interview with mike patton who i love
and this chef
and they were talking about food and i
thought this was going to be great but
it was just they were like in their
separate boxes
what do you like to eat well i like
italian food i like what do you eat i
eat french food
and that's how that's how it went for an
hour i'm like going i know this
could have been great if they were
sitting next to each other um but i
guess you beggars can't be
choosers so uh i just coined that just
so you know
uh and it'll be the title of my next
book impressive but um
yeah thank you the uh i'm sorry
but that's that it's it's it's like i'm
doing the five today
i'll be doing it in a location and
it's not fun waiting to do it and it's
it's just like you know when you you
know when you do remotes on tv
for a whole hour it's it's just and like
the sound is weird and
i don't know it's just like i can't i'm
not having i'm not having as much fun
but again i can't complain because if
this is my complaint during the
coronavirus that i'm not having as much
fun
then you know i'm an [ __ ] because i'm
here i'm
healthy right now you know i've been
tested i'm negative
uh you know and and uh so that's okay so
eve
have you ever though i know you had the
coronavirus thing yet have you had that
they have the swap
i have it's not that bad the swab and as
far as i know i have not had the corona
and look it's 80 and sunny every day in
l.a i believe vitamin d
that's my personal scientific thing that
now i mean a lot of people believe that
and it is actual science vitamin d is
science
you should read up on um how sunscreen
has hindered vitamin d production in
your body there's a great article in
outside magazine from january
2019 blew my mind when people put on a
lot of sunscreen they block the vitamin
d that comes in
and so that actually raises your risk
for other
illnesses so could sunscreen cause the
corona virus mr rubin
i ask you that exit questions media
matters will let us know
they will let us know um wait i wanna i
wanna talk since we're
since we're talking about the remote
thing a little bit i want to talk about
new york city because normally
you do live in new york city at least
some of the time um
but you're you're in your forest now
you're undisclosed location in the
forest
yes do you think new york city's ever
going to come back from this
and and what about the violence and just
the the whole thing now because it's not
just about the the virus anymore it's so
sad
i got to tell you so saturday i was in
manhattan and it was great i'm walking
around
to oho and and like everybody's drinking
outside because you can now drink
outside
but there's a lot of cars exhausts and
it's not that great but you know what
it's turned it into kind of a fun place
but everything's closed
every and i'm watching i i ended up
talking to a friend of mine who
lives next door and he's lived in new
york for 40 years
and he's been through everything and
he's a tough dude
harley ride-in dude and he's like my
heart broke
and he was talking about sunday the
sunday night in june when
uh everything was looted and my wife was
stuck in the apartment
um and uh i was just just blows my mind
and and
it was just a horrible horrible horrible
experience and
i wrote about this i don't know if you
saw the article but i wrote about it it
reminded me of when my friend's car got
stolen and they found the car
and the insurance wouldn't total it
because it was still working but nobody
wanted to get in the car
because something had been done inside
the car like they
pissed in it um they had just they had
soiled metaphorically literally the car
and my buddy said you know what they're
not totaling it but i don't want this
and he was you know he was a college kid
and so he had you know he
just didn't have his car anymore it was
a mustang but that's how i like
when i feel when i'm walking around soho
i feel like my god this thing was
assaulted
it was assaulted and it hasn't recovered
and it's it's
and uh and i'm looking at the at the all
the spray paint all the messages the
political messages
and how we're all supposed to genuflect
and i'm going but what about all the
people that work here that don't have
jobs right now
and i'm watching people that come here
to shop that are like that aren't rich
that are coming here because they heard
there might be sales and nothing is open
and there's some stores that are open
and then there are other stores that
aren't and then you hear about
uh there was another some other looting
that happened and
um it's just it to me i don't think it's
gonna come i mean i'm
okay so i have this conversation i don't
care if my wife might get back
i have this conversation with my wife
almost every night i want to move she
doesn't
and she because she's an optimist and
also becomes because she moved from
moscow
so it's like she moved to moscow and
london and i think that
anything freedom to her freedom is
everything so it's like greg you're
living in the freest country in the
world and this is part of the
consequences of your freedoms
this happening i mean if this wouldn't
happen in moscow everybody probably
would be lined up somewhere
but that's what happened she goes so
this is why it's you know this is why
it's important
and i'm like but um i don't
i don't feel safe here i don't think you
i think that it's going to happen again
in fact i believe that any time now that
we've opened the door for this
you can go in that door any time you
want uh the mayor
de blasio made the cops hold back uh we
saw what happened
um and it was it was i mean you could
call the cops and it wasn't nothing was
going to happen
so we i have this conversation every day
it breaks my heart i love where i live
but um i want to get i kind of want to
get the hell out of there
but i am patient and maybe i think so i
have been wrong
i tend to exaggerate things i because
i'm neurotic so i might be wrong on this
as well
that maybe new york it came back after 9
11
and maybe we'll get a maybe we'll get a
mayor that's amazing
maybe maybe a police chief will run or
maybe uh i don't know who
something will happen and this will
change um so that's
that that's the yeah that's the silver
lining thing right like the silver
lining has to be
well you've been talking about the uh
the silent majority a lot and it's like
that these people will finally they
weren't political or they never spoke up
and they're still not speaking up now
and the polls don't reflect it
but come election time that there will
just be this giant
uprising of people that are like yeah
you know we thought about it and america
is pretty decent
so we're going to keep going with
america yeah i hope so i really do
that's yes and by my book the plus
because it's incredibly positive
it's positive it's gung-ho it's gonna
change your life if your life is like
this
it will be like this when you're done
reading the book or possibly like this
and then you can just move on over and
crush that past self
that doesn't exist anymore that old self
is dead after you read that book
so it's in effect you're like killing
someone with this book yes
i'm killing i'm i'm creating a better
version a simulation
of you i don't know if that's possible
but i'm trying
yeah uh listen you're gay you're a very
busy guy you gave me an hour is there
anything else on the book that
that we didn't hit i mean anyone that
that knows you will dig
it's fun it's not too serious but you do
make good points about
just getting your [ __ ] together and and
going ahead and living a decent life and
that came at the right time
everything and it wasn't pla i didn't
plan it which makes me think it's going
to do well because
i didn't plan it things i plan never go
well things i don't plan
explode so it's like i think this is
gonna do well because it wasn't on the
it wasn't on schedule i just felt like i
had to do it so it came from the heart
although people question whether i
really have one dave
greg am i sending these people to amazon
or do you have a
spec a specific website for the book
gutfelt.com
or amazon or barnes and noble any place
you want to go
but i would frequent all of them many
times and buy your you know what a good
bundle would be to get my book and
dave's book
well their second copy of my book
yes all right gutfeld i will
see you i'm sure on your show in the not
too yes definitely and watch this i've
got a new outro here
if you know someone i can't wait who
might appreciate a different viewpoint
be sure and share this video
by clicking the share arrow below
thanks cutfeld do you have a picture of
cher
there because you should can we in we
gotta insert or share a picture
[Laughter]
or share from um what's the movie with
what's her face the vegetarian
mad in the control room i need the
vegetarian in the movie what's the girl
that's a vegetarian with the
clueless or have a picture of cher from
clueless
oh cher from clueless her name was cher
alicia silverstone there you go
yes yes good god we greg you're like
it's like playing charades
with a young person with no memory
that is you just nailed it if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell